what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar
and as i'm writing this my first ever
avatar video about every known vending
style is already over 100
000 views so i thought it was about time
to make another avatar video
since many of you clearly wanted to see
more to keep the avatar train going
make sure to turn that like button blue
like the arrow tattoo on aang's head
and share this video with your cultured
avatar friends if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial ring that
notification bell or you will miss
future avatar videos
leave suggestions for avatar videos
you'd like to see next
in the comments now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and
all fun fact initially i wanted this to
be my first avatar video topic but then
i got obsessed with all the different
kinds of bending and one thing led to
another
now though i finally get to go through
every avatar from oldest to the most
recent
if you somehow didn't know yet the
avatar is a figure in this series that
is supposed to maintain the balance of
the world and can potentially learn
every type of bending that exists
unlike everyone else the avatar is
reincarnated and usually has access to
his or her previous reincarnations
although this gets complicated as we'll
see later on in the video there have
been countless avatars
and we don't know enough about all of
them to talk about them here
so again this video is focused on the
ones we know enough about to talk about
now let's start with the first ever
avatar juan who existed around 10
000 years before korra's time in juan's
time
people lived on different lion turtles
who could temporarily let people borrow
the power of the elements
the world was also overrun by spirits so
the lion turtles
helped to keep the relatively weak
humans safe juan
was from the fire lion turtle who
initially gave him the ability to
firebend
at first like the others he used it as
simply a tool but after living with the
spirits
he developed the dancing dragon fire
bending form by copying the motion
of a dragon and firebending eventually
became an extension of his body
unlike those before him juan mastered
higher level fire bending moves like
summoning greater amounts of fire
redirecting an enemy's fire back at them
deflecting fire and using it like a jet
pack
fire bending remained his preferred
element of choice however he did go to
other lion turtles in order to gain the
power of the other elements
he learned how to launch air blasts and
create an air cloud for transportation
with air bending how to launch water and
use it like a whip with water bending
and how to launch boulders and launch
himself into the air with earth bending
he could only use the elements one at a
time though
until he permanently fused his soul with
rava the spirit of light and peace aka
the avatar spirit once fused
he could use all the powers at the same
time and enter the avatar's state which
would boost his existing strength
although juan did not succeed in
bringing about perfect peace in his
lifetime
because of rava they could keep working
on it because they would continue to be
reincarnated through the avatar cycle
we know of avatar salai as well who is
remembered as one of the greatest
avatars
we're gonna breeze past this one because
unfortunately we don't know much else
about this avatar
aside from the fact that he came before
avatar zetto
avatar zetto came from the fire nation
because of natural disasters and feuds
between the nation's noble clans
the fire nation was severely threatened
this avatar was unique in a sense
because despite being the avatar
he joined his nation's government and
worked as a bureaucrat
diplomat and even accountant rejecting
his avatar privileges he worked his way
up like anyone else to the position of
grand advisor to fire lord yosor
whereas the fire nation had to be nerfed
later on at this point this avatar
decided that he needed to help save it
we don't see much of this avatar's
powers although in a spiritual vision
aang did see him in avatar mode
lava bending the magma from get this for
volcanoes
so you know he was a force to be
reckoned with he just might hold the
record for being the most overpowered
accountant
of all time right after zetto we get air
nomad avatar yang chen
aka the great young chen she died about
345 years before the fire nation wiped
out the air nomad
yang chen was pretty machiavellian for
an air nomad avatar
usually air nomads would be pacifists
aka people who believe that war violence
killing and so on are unjustifiable
and they also taught detachment from the
physical realm
but yang chen despite being an air nomad
was against this type of philosophy for
the avatar
in her view the avatar had to devote
themselves to the physical world
and do everything within their power to
maintain balance even if that meant
killing as she told aang in the last
airbender on a side note it is
cool seeing different avatar
reincarnations and how they can vary in
their philosophies
aing did not sacrifice his own spiritual
needs by killing ozai
as yangchan suggested rather he avoided
killing
and stayed true to his own beliefs by
taking away the fire lord's bending
powers
showing that there are different ways of
maintaining balance it should be
noted though that young chen's approach
was so effective
that no threats of war occurred for an
entire generation after her death
yang chen was also the most powerful
bender of her day and mastered all the
elements in her youth
as an air nomad she mastered airbending
first and thus received her blue arrow
tattoo
in the avatar state using all of the
elements in tandem
young chen could overpower the powerful
spirit old iron and although she was
willing to do whatever it took to carry
out her duty
she'd prefer to solve conflicts without
killing or even using violence if
possible for instance
with the fifth nation pirates she used a
treaty to secure peace
she made similar pacts with humans and
spirits as was the case with spirit old
iron
in the end yangchen would be remembered
as a great imbalanced avatar
who could use brain and brawn to get the
job done
after yangchen came the northern water
tribe avatar kuruk
he was born 345 years before the fire
nation wiped out the air nomads
and lived for 33 years one of the cool
things about kuruk
is that like uncle airo he was into pi's
show
the chess of the avatar world after he
mastered all of the elements
he continued to ask his surprise
companions for more bending training
because like a pie show grand master
he realized that learning never stopped
and that his skills could keep growing
with constant challenges
once after he mastered all the elements
he went to an uninhabited island
where avatar young chen waterbended for
the first time so that he could learn to
control the avatar state
he accidentally ended up destroying the
entire island when he entered the avatar
state for the first time
things took an especially dark turn for
kuruk after he visited
the spirit world and encountered a dark
spirit he'd go on to fight many dark
spirits and he would lose his own
vitality in the process
and fall into a deep depression when he
destroyed dark spirits it was causing
damage to his own spirit
kuruk kept this stuff secret so to the
outside world
kuruk just looked like a terrible avatar
he would sleep through meetings
get drunk and trust others to work
things out for him he was a big time
womanizer
and would even use air bending to create
a tornado of flowers in order to impress
women
the stress and depression led him to
live a hedonistic lifestyle that was
pretty much the exact
opposite of jung chen's approach when he
wasn't fighting dark spirits
he would search for opponents whether
human or spirit
and challenge them to bending contests
for fun he would challenge firebenders
to agnikais or
earthbenders to boulder lifting contests
things briefly seemed like they turned
around when he met his future wife umi
he fell in love at first sight but on
their wedding day she got dragged to the
spirit world by ko the face dealer
to punish kuruk for his past ways so
just when things seem to be getting
better
the spirit world strikes again and
devastates kuruk he spent
every wedding anniversary searching for
his wife in the spirit world
but he didn't find her before he died at
33 years old making him the shortest
lived known avatar he continued
searching for his wife in the spirit
world but eventually found
out that coe the face stealer had stolen
her face and that killing the spirit
would mean killing what was left of his
wife
so he let the spirit live this dude is
considered to be the worst of avatars
because even though young chen did such
a good job and paved the way for peace
so well
kuruk neglected his avatar duties in the
real world
and it led to many political problems
after his death
his life spiraled out of control but
kuruk was very gifted
no bender could beat him in sparring
matches he was considered to be the
greatest pie show player of all time
showing that he wasn't just strong but
smart too he was considered to be the
best hunter ever
and he used his skills to kill powerful
dark spirit after powerful dark spirit
he even damaged the strongest spirit he
faced
father glowworm enough so that this
spirit couldn't cause any more damage
for a good while afterwards
kuruk was so talented he practically
excelled at anything he took
seriously he may be remembered as one of
the worst avatars but he was one of the
most interesting ones
and he illustrated just how human and
flawed the avatar could truly be
after him came avatar kyoshi who was
born 312 years before the fire nation
wiped out the air nomads
while kuruk only lived to be 33 years
old kyoshi lived to be
230 years old which is pretty shocking
she was born to the earth kingdom and
she grew to be extremely tall
ironically kyoshi was born to criminals
including a runaway heir nomad nun
named jessa and a thief from a poor
earth kingdom family of actors named
hark
while her signature gold headdress and
metal fans are from her mother her
signature makeup comes from her father's
face paint
interestingly enough no one knew she was
the avatar until she was 16.
her parents had abandoned her which led
to periods of starvation
and later she even worked as a servant
very humble beginnings for an avatar
indeed
as an avatar kyoshi could obviously bend
all four elements and enter the avatar
state
she started out as an earthbender rather
than an airbender like her mother
curiously she was initially able to bend
large amounts of earth but not small
amounts
which is the opposite of how it usually
works obviously though
she would go on to improve her
earthbending skills she could breathe
fire and she would use her mother's
metal fans
to enhance her air bending she was good
enough at waterbending to raise ships
and then freeze them in ice she was an
absolute beast
strength-wise she could lift a grown man
with one hand even as a teenager
combine that raw strength with her
mastery over tessen jutsu aka the
martial art of fighting with fans
and you got yourself a deadly fighter
even before you add in all of the
elements and avatar powers
kyoshi was willing to kill people to
maintain peace and she tended to send
them dropping to their doom
in one instance she came up against chin
the conqueror who wanted to conquer the
continent
including the peninsula where kyoshi
lived kyoshi did the unthinkable
she used earth and lava bending to
separate the peninsula from the mainland
and then used airbending to move the
newly created island
i don't think i've seen anything more
impressive in this series than this
i love lava bending a very rare and op
sub-skill of earth bending and it's
awesome that kyoshi knew how to use it
chin the conqueror and warlord
happened to fall off a cliff as a result
of the avatar's actions
however kyoshi said she would have
killed him directly
if she needed to she also learned about
the secret of immortality from lao gay
which allowed her to reconstruct a
deteriorating body
over and over again thus she seems to
have used his secrets to maintain her
appearance
and to live for 230 years in her
lifetime kyoshi
created the kyoshi warriors and the
daily historically significant groups
that would continue to exist long after
her death
although she did regret forming the
daily because of how corrupt they became
in conclusion she started from the
bottom and became an extremely powerful
and mostly well-remembered avatar who
had mastery over the elements
new lava bending new martial arts had
one of the most unique looks of any
avatar and was more than willing to kill
someone if she deemed it necessary
obviously there is more that i could say
about the details of her life
but this is an overview video of each
avatar so i'll be moving on if you do
want a more in-depth video breakdown
about a specific avatar
just let me know in the comments after
kyoshi came the fire nation avatar roku
he was born 82 years before the fire
nation wiped out the air nomads
if yoshi was in his position she
probably would have killed lord sozen
before he could start a hundred year war
but sozen lacked the decisiveness and
deeply regretted it
from the afterlife he went on to help
aang his successor
in the hopes that aang could right his
wrongs by 28 years old roku
had mastered all four elements and was
able to control the avatar state
he would live to be 70 years old avatar
roku could also
lava bend and he had insane control of
his bending he could melt people's
chains
without harming them at all he could
also use an airbender glider like aang
create tornadoes that let him fly and
create large air barriers
that could cover an entire village he
could also tunnel through the ground
like a skilled earthbender
and move large quantities of water roku
was strong enough to easily overpower
firelord soza in a fair fight
he probably could have handled an
erupting volcano too
if it wasn't for the poisonous volcanic
gases that eventually did him in
he was 70 years old at the time and fire
lord sozen betrayed him after the avatar
had saved his life
multiple times on the volcano on a side
note avatar roku's
animal guide was a dragon named fang
dragons are considered to be the first
firebenders
and they would definitely be my animal
guide of choice
in the end like most avatars roku was
very powerful
he single-handedly kept the skilled fire
lord solzen and the entire fire nation
in check
while he was alive some more notable
accomplishments include the time he
temporarily took over aang's body
and easily out firebended four fire
sages and commander zhao
no small feat his air bending would cool
lava into land immediately
and was powerful enough to easily tear
through buildings
he initially struggled with water
bending his elemental opposite
but his water bending eventually became
good enough so that he could defeat his
teacher
in a duel with just one massive wave and
with earthbending
he was especially skilled as i mentioned
lava bending is very rare
much rarer than metal bending so the
fact that roku could do it is impressive
in and of itself he also managed to beat
his earth bending teacher in an earth
bending wave race
up a mountain and not only that he even
had enough time to make tea for them
before his teacher arrived
now that's a flex if i've ever seen one
after roku we get our very own avatar
aang he was born 12 years before the
fire nation wiped out his fellow air
nomads
a bit before the fire nation attacked
and began the hundred year war
aang was frozen in ice only to emerge
100 years later
he was biologically 12 years old still
but he was technically 112 years old
when he met katara and saka
he would go on to live until he was
biologically around 66 years old
although he was 166 years old
chronologically
among his notable feats he saved the
world as a 12 year old by learning all
the elements and even energy bending in
less than a year
as we saw with kyoshi who learned she
was the avatar at 16 years old aang
mastered all the elements and saved the
world
before many avatars even knew they were
avatars after he defeated the leader
of the strongest nation firelord ozai he
finally began a romantic relationship
with katara
and they eventually had three kids bumi
a non-bender that would go on to develop
airbending powers in legend of korra
kaya a waterbender and tenzin an
airbender who would go on to keep the
air nomad tradition alive by passing it
on to his own children
aang was an exceptionally gifted
airbender at age
six he was better than airbenders twice
his age
at age 10 he was better than his own
airbending teachers
and at age 12 he earned his airbending
tattoos and became the youngest
airbending master
in nomad history up to that point at
this point aang had already invented the
epic air scooter
which is the controlled sphere of air
that he rides around throughout the
series
aang was told that he was the avatar 12
years old because there were signs that
a war was approaching
traditionally they'd wait until the
avatar is 16
to let them know aang was burdened by
this title and responsibility
and it didn't help matters that he was
ostracized from the other kids
and forced to practice airbending more
and more monkeyatso was the only one who
empathized with aang and
seemed to understand his burden but the
other monks felt that he was too soft on
aang
so they were going to separate the two
friends this was the last straw farang
he ran away got caught in a storm and
then the avatar staked kicked in
in order to save him and oppa his flying
bison from drowning
using airbending and water bending he
sealed them in a sphere of ice
and they stayed there for the next 100
years in the meantime
the hundred year war began and the air
nomads were wiped out
aang wasn't there to help because he
shirked his responsibilities as avatar
by running away and as a result he
blamed himself for all the destruction
and death that the hundred year war
caused fortunately
he was given a chance to redeem himself
and he did by defeating fire lord ozai
and bringing peace and justice to the
world in regards to bending sub skills
aang was the first known avatar to use
lightning redirection of subset of
firebending
and seismic sense a subset of earth
bending that allows the user to detect
people's movements by sensing vibrations
in the ground
he did not seem to learn lava bending
metal bending blood bending and so on
which in a sense is cool for other
characters because it gives them a
chance to surpass the avatar in a way
which makes the story more interesting
to me it would be kind of boring if the
avatar
automatically became the best lava
bender bloodbender and so on
in legend of korra we do get some
glimpses of adult aang
at 40 years old aang stopped yacon yacon
was a powerful bloodbender
who didn't need the full moon in order
to bend blood he used blood bending
during his trial to make everyone
including aang faint
aang woke up first thanks to his avatar
state and we saw how much his mastery
over the air scooter
had improved the air scooter was much
larger and could stand on it rather than
sit on it
kind of like a surfer and he could
easily catch up to a horse using it
interestingly enough it seems that in
his avatar state even the most powerful
blood bending had no effect on him at
this point
and then ang proceeded to energy ben
yacon's abilities away
one of the most impressive instances of
water bending we saw was when ang merged
with the ocean spirit law
in order to form koizilla together they
completely devastated all the fire
nation forces that were attacking the
northern water tribe
it was like avatar state eng was
fighting in a giant water bending mecca
that could slice
metal like it was nothing and could
create massive waves
that would leave the huge fire nation
ships powerless
although ing was naturally talented in
water bending it wasn't his element of
choice when it came to battle and the
more disciplined katara eventually
surpassed him
and became his water bending teacher
katara herself
learned to use blood bending during full
moons a bending ability she had
that avatar aang did not although earth
bending was aang's elemental opposite
and so gave him some trouble at first it
did eventually become his second most
used bending style after air bending one
of my favorite earth-bending abilities
was when aang would surround his body
with earth and
armor of course he could also do simple
things like launch
boulders or raise defensive walls from
the ground he would also often use
earth to trap his opponents without
killing them he used this ability
against yacon as well
in the comics aang also created a giant
body out of earth that he used to fight
against the already mentioned
general old iron they could exchange
blows but the giant spirit had iron
armor which was stronger so aang needed
a little help from toff and her metal
bending students
but still this giant earthen mecha would
have allowed aang to flex on almost
any other opponent when it came to fire
bending ink had a complicated
relationship to it at first
because he was careless and accidentally
hurt katara however he did eventually
come back to it
and zuko trained him he could unleash
powerful streams of fire from his mouth
and arms at the same time
and while his firebending was made
stronger by sozen's comet
he succeeded in taking down a fire
nation airship with one firebending shot
during his fight against the fire lord
in the avatar state
aing could release five powerful streams
of fire
one from his mouth two from his arms and
two from his legs
he could then condense all that
firepower into a ring that circled
around him and of course
as mentioned he learned to redirect
lightning from zuko as well
a highly advanced fire bending technique
aing was also one of the few avatars to
learn
and use energy bending i briefly
mentioned his energy bending but let me
go into a little more detail here
it is very dangerous because one's own
life energy has to be unbendable in
order to bend another's energy
or else the bender will become corrupted
and possibly destroyed
ain clearly improved his energy bending
over time because his 40 year old
self could take away a cones bending
like it was nothing
while it was portrayed as a pretty big
deal when he initially used it against
fire lord ozai
it was also ang spirit that would use
energy bending on korra
in order to restore her bending
abilities after they were taken away
through the use of blood bending his
spirit also proceeds to transfer his
knowledge of how to energy bend to korra
unlike korra aang was unnatural when it
came to spiritual stuff
probably because of his air nomad
background he could meditate and thereby
enter the spiritual world even as a
child
his spirit could separate from his body
and travel through the physical world
as an astral projection in fact it was
his spiritual affinity
that in part allowed him to fuse with
the ocean spirit in order to create
koizilla
as i mentioned aang died at 66 years old
which may seem kind of young
it wasn't an epic opponent that did him
in it was just the fact that the 100
years
he spent frozen did actually drain his
life energy thus his health failed him
sooner than it would have otherwise
aang knew that he was nearing his end
and he tasked the order of the white
lotus
to find and look after his next
reincarnation as we all probably know
his next reincarnation turned out to be
korra from the southern water tribe
she was born 153 years after the fire
nation
wiped out the air nomads we talked about
how ang learned all the elements at 12
years old although some may argue that
it was 112
but you know what i mean at the
biological age of 12 he learned all the
elements
which is huge since as we saw it was
traditional for the avatar to only find
out they were the avatar at 16 years old
meaning they probably wouldn't have used
any bending style
other than their native one up to that
point cora like aang knew that she was
the avatar before 16.
in fact at only 4 years old she could
perform water earth and fire bending but
it took her a long time to learn air
bending aang's strongest bending style
according to tenzin aang's airbending
son korra had a lot of trouble with
airbending because it was the most
opposite to her personality
she was 17 years old when she finally
learned airbending despite her initial
trouble
korra became quite adept at air bending
over time she learned to use a glider
to use the air scooter and even to
create air bubbles around people's heads
that could provide them with oxygen
and protect them from poisonous gases
it's kind of like the opposite of how
zaheer
could use air betting to deprive people
of oxygen air bending eventually became
cora's second most used bending style
water bending korra's native element was
taught to her by katara for over a
decade
she can create massive waves is well
versed in water whips
and can create large ice walls as well
cora can also draw water from thin air
not needing a pre-existing water source
in order to water bend however we have
never seen her use the outlawed and
overpowered skill of blood bending
she did learn healing from katara though
who was regarded as the best healer in
the world
katara also learned how to spirit bend
using water
which involves pacifying spirits by
changing their negative energy into
positive energy
she learned this from her uncle unalloc
and eventually used it against him in
order to defeat him after he fused with
the dark spear of vatu and became the
dark avatar
now that her uncle is dead korra is the
only living person we know of
who can use this type of bending when it
comes to fire cora can use breath of
fire
melt through metal chains and even use
fire bending as a form of propulsion
like a jetpack
while the avatar usually has trouble
with their opposite element cora didn't
have trouble with fire because it suited
her personality so well
the element worked well with her fiery
spirit and natural assertiveness
cora is a very skilled earthbender she's
often able to launch
giant boulders raise up defensive walls
and easily flip cars
using earthbending she can manipulate a
large radius of earth around
her and cause a lot of damage to
buildings you definitely do not want her
earth bending in your office
interestingly enough cora is the first
ever avatar
to learn metal bending but we don't see
her using the more rare and op
lava bending that epic bending style is
reserved for team avatar member bolin
then there's energy bending as i
mentioned aang restored korra's bending
abilities after they were taken away
with blood bending
and at the same time he passed on to her
the knowledge of energy bending
after that she could restore other
people's bending as well
cora eventually reaches a whole other
level of energy bending she becomes able
to create a huge blue astral projection
of her spirit
in this form she can launch giant energy
blasts from her body
that overpowered the dark avatar she was
even able to bend water in this spirit
form
though she was disconnected from her
physical body she was even able to use
energy bending to protect herself and
kuvira from the spirit beam
the strongest weapon known to man after
cora made a connection to aang
and the past avatars she learned how to
enter the avatar stayed at will
however because of the damage rava the
avatar spirit suffered
during the fight against the dark avatar
cora lost her connection to all of her
past
lives so korra and future avatars will
not be able to seek guidance from the
avatars of the past
which sucks big time but at least korra
was able to eventually stop the dark
avatar and save the world
korra's avatar journey so far was filled
with highs and lows
she fought stronger opponents than aang
but she also started fighting those
opponents at an older age
she was 17 when the series started and
21 during book
4. she lost the invaluable connection to
the previous avatars but she also
decided to leave the spirit portals open
and that led to the awakening of a bunch
of new airbenders
which is amazing aang would have been
glad to see airbenders return to the
world
in such large numbers she beat opponents
like the scary bloodbender amman
the spirit of darkness and chaos known
as vatu
the philosophically interesting zaheer
who learned to straight up fly
and kuvira the metal bending tyrant who
used some of the most dangerous weapons
we've ever seen
including a giant platinum mecca and the
spirit energy cannon
each one of these opponents was insanely
powerful in their own way
so you gotta give korra the credit she
deserves for being able to eventually
overcome each one of them
as we saw in this video many avatars had
their low moments
as did korra but when push came to shove
korra pulled through
and that is it for this video all known
avatars
and their powers explained it was quite
the long one and took a bunch of work
so if you did enjoy this video and want
to see more avatar videos like it
please turn that like button blue to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial ring that
notification bell or you will miss
future avatar videos
let me know who your favorite avatar is
in the comments below and you can leave
any suggestions you have for future
videos below as well
a very special thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
alpha and are the one-tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grana alolan
autumn the world steelers acquire
respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon of
isles papa smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones and ken mono
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated overall champion of the
world
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor
jessica kayla font hinokamian water
bonnie parks rethuan dayora deadly saint
and stern hawkins thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animehelppro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime pro
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you